sleeping dogs as the series had a rough
development not only did the original
get delayed multiple times but its
planned sequel and future spin-off game
were outright cancelled
according to vg charts sleeping dogs had
only sold about a million copies within
its first year
way below the expectations of the
developers sadly i haven't found any
info past this so there's no way to know
if the game gained a ton more sales in a
future year but looking at the
previously mentioned info about its
future titles it seems that it never
really caught on
as much as they wanted to but despite
this the game garnered a large
following of eager fans under many
youtube videos about the game you'll see
countless comments from fans of the
series who all agree
sleeping dogs is an underrated gem and
deserves a sequel so let's talk about
sleeping dogs the most underrated game
of all time
[Music]
so sleeping dogs is a third person open
world brawler
i usually hate using other games as a
comparison but to help
some people understand the game a bit
more it's got that open world and
intriguing story elements many games of
its genre have but also the combat of
the batman arkham games
world 1v12 is not only possible but
actually a fair fight the game takes
place in hong kong china a lovely set
piece for the game
it's on a large map compared to other
games of the same genre but i never saw
this as a problem
some open world games suffer from having
large maps with little content making
you travel miles just to find something
souping dogs went for the smaller but
more packed map approach and it
complements the game
quite well the story stars our
protagonist wei shen who seems to be a
criminal of some sort as he's dealing
with some contraband to some gang
members we see multiple angles from
outside the deal and we discover that
the police are waiting to arrest them
the deal goes wrong and the police
intervene
wei and his friend flee the scene and we
get introduced to the parkour mechanics
of the game allowing chase scenes to
feel more smooth and action-packed it's
not as deep as say assassin's creed as
you aren't allowed to climb any wall you
see but assuming the ledge isn't too
high up you can most definitely climb it
way gets caught and brought in for
questioning until the cameras get turned
off and we see that way was actually an
undercover cop
working with the police to put those
guys in jail it's a nice twist to the
start of the game
ways once again working with the police
but more specifically pen drew raymond
and inspector tane to bring down the sun
on ye
that's why earlier we see wei talking
with jackie as he's the easiest way to
get into the gang
whey grew up in hong kong most of the
guys in the sanan yi are from a town
called
old prosperity so they were all
childhood friends at one point back in
the day so it makes sense that he's the
undercover agent for this mission
raymond however is concerned claiming
wei may have some personal vendettas as
way blames the death of his family on
the triad gangs of hong kong so it makes
sense that things may get a bit too
personal jackie walks with us to the
golden koi so he can introduce us to the
gang but a group of punks arrive and try
to start some [ __ ] with us
this is where the arkham game combat is
introduced i think this was actually
quite smart the enemies in this section
only push you and while it does do
damage it's extremely minor
this section is an intertwined tutorial
i've always liked it when the tutorial
doesn't feel like one
yes there are tips and button prompts
but i've never liked when the game
teaches you shooting or
fighting and enemies conveniently show
up like they were forced to fight you
because the tutorial said so even though
we don't know who they are
and have little info about the game's
story we could assume that they don't
like
jackie or are a rival gang to the sun on
ye this gives meaning
albeit small to this encounter which is
better than none at
all the tutorial does a pretty good job
of teaching the player the basic
mechanics of offensive fighting while
also letting the player know that you
can use your environment to your
advantage when we get to the golden coin
we meet some of the gangs specifically
winston
and conroy neither like us at the moment
and conrad used this time to fight us so
we can prove that we aren't a weak link
after a fight a man named dog eyes
appears and winston doesn't seem too
happy to see him and
neither does way hey who's the new blood
this way
you remember mimi shen back when you
first started getting girls with big
smiley oh
mimi oh yeah first girl ever
suck my [ __ ] so what
razor brother minus the parkour showcase
were about 10 minutes into the game and
already were introduced to numerous
characters with varying personalities
jackie always feels like the gang's
younger brother the one who is respected
amongst everyone and picked on the most
as he's seen as the younger brother
currently conroy and winston feel the
same two hard asses doing what's right
for the gang but this will slowly change
and evolve over the course of the game
and then doga is someone who has more
confidence charisma and sarcasm than
anyone we've met so far
he's extremely cocky and loves to
provoke people this separates the
characters a ton
making them feel like actual characters
not copy pasted npcs put in a game
because the devs needed characters for
the player to meet
what's not clear right now as the game
progresses we see the characters evolve
showing different emotions not shown in
the beginning moments of the game which
once again ultimately
makes them feel more real the next 20
minutes or so is more combat and chase
scenes as well as introducing the player
to a few more elements of the game like
food vendors and clothing shops
we do however get to see the cop and
triad experience trees which give us
upgrades when we level up we gain triad
rank by fighting gang members and we
lose cop rank by destroying property or
killing civilians
these become very handy as the game
progresses the last portion of this
introduction however is quite important
we see way get arrested and questioned
again
has to blow our cover and explain that
we are an undercover cop trying to bring
down the sun on ye
not join them this was an excellent
piece of critical storytelling i tend to
nitpick games a bit too much and this
halted one of my biggest nitpicks from
years ago when i first played for the
first time
why do the cops arrest us when we're a
cop ourselves i assumed that maybe they
were playing along but why would they
willingly get killed to play the part
this shut down my biggest question and i
was genuinely impressed they even
mentioned this
after this cutscene though we are given
the option to explore the open world
while i was originally going to discuss
the exploration and the open world of
the game first as that'd be a really
nice transition
i want to go in depth on sleeping dogs
most important mechanic
it's combat
combat as stated before is the most
important mechanic of the game it was
definitely the one that took the most
development time too
if 85 percent of your game is saturn
around one mechanic then you have to put
lots of time into that to make sure you
do it right and sleeping dogs does this
flawlessly while the game does have both
shooting and fighting combat i'll focus
on the hand-to-hand combat first the fun
in combat is centered around three
buttons you have your attack your
counter and your grapple button they are
fairly self-explanatory at a basic level
but do get more complex past this
you can string at most a five hit combo
you can also end it short by holding the
attack button which delivers a swift
kick to the opponent so for an example
you could throw five punches in one
string or four punches and one kick
of course there are different variations
of the kick depending on when you stop
the combo
a combo consisting of one punch and one
kick is a lot different than when you do
three punches and one kick
they all do damage to the opponent but
depending on your situation one may be
suited better than the other
for example throwing five straight
punches at more tougher and bigger
enemies will have them counter-attack
you causing you to have some health loss
another example is maybe you want to do
some devastating damage really quickly
depending on the upgrades you have
instead of kneeing them you can follow
up with a more devastating kick
afterwards last sentence i subtly
mentioned upgrading after meeting the
dojo master for the first time he will
mention that if you find any of his
missing statues out in the world he will
offer to teach you new moves if we
return them to him just like the one we
mentioned
there are 11 in total to collect and
you'll most likely come across them in
the story content anyway as they're
really hard to miss
you're obviously not going to be the
only one fighting however your opponent
will have a red outline around them when
they attempt to kick by pressing the
counter button you can perform a counter
attack leaving them vulnerable to more
hits the last one
is a grapple this is a lot more helpful
than it may seem as some enemies who
block can be broken by grappling them
and it also sets you up to perform
environmental attacks which also glow
red the combat technically stops here
but like any other fighting game of its
kind sleeping dogs adds variety and
enemies to keep you on your toes while
fighting your basic enemies are strikers
skinny guys that can be grappled without
fail brawlers are a bit more muscular
and block most of your attacks then
there's the grapplers huge fat guys who
will grapple and throw you to the ground
they hit the hardest and cannot be
grappled unless you have a full face
meter the face meter is the yellow bar
in the bottom left when it reaches full
capacity you can gain health in combat
as well as small other benefits like
grabbing those big guys we mentioned
among other things
one thing that's sometimes overlooked in
fighting combat is the ability to commit
to attacks
with this game you can seemingly do
unnatural movements but it's added to
make the combat smoother we can throw a
kick at someone and while the kick is
still going he can stop the kick right
away and have enough time to block an
incoming punch
it looks weird and unnatural but if it
wasn't part of the combat it would
destroy completely it makes the flow
from offense to defense feel
smooth and not clunky as if this wasn't
added you'd have to wait to attack as
you'd be worried that you'd be punished
for attacking first as others can swing
right after you
and while in some games that may be fine
and sleeping dogs is combat it's always
won against
many and that would be awful if this
wasn't implemented as i stated before
the majority of the game is fist
fighting other gang members and the best
place to test your skill is a martial
arts club there's a set amount of rounds
and enemies per round as each one gets
progressively harder and harder and more
people hop in to fight sometimes being
one of those grapplers or brawlers we
mentioned
this by far is the best side content in
the game fighting games like this are
always entertaining it's why i love the
arkham game so much besides the
excellent narrative
the fighting never feels boring as
enemies are always different whether
it's the number of people in the fight
to the types of fighters it's always
going to be different but that's where
this lacks for me
each club has the same number of rounds
and same enemy types per round so you
can always know what to expect that's
why i wish
this game of all games had challenge
runs like the ones from dishonored or if
i'm gonna compare it a third time
the arkham games the missions are always
centered around fighting and are
different from the next
being able to do small challenges like
no grapples or only punches would be a
small yet genius implementation the
small challenges could be sometimes
annoying winter districts one of the
main core parts of the combat so having
a few sections sprinkled in here and
there of just raw fighting with
large numbers like the martial arts club
without the consistent enemy numbers
would have been an amazing addition to
this game
i personally love the fighting in this
game i don't want to stop fighting so i
always do the martial arts club as the
quickest and easiest form of constant
combat but after a while the numbers of
enemies per round is predictable and now
you're fighting with the knowledge of
knowing who's going to enter the fight
but that's not the fun of the combat the
fun is not knowing who's going to show
up
for one moment it could be 9 different
guys some have knives and cleavers other
are different enemy types
and once you think you've finally beaten
them using everything you've gotten at
your disposal
even more show up and now there's even
more knife wielders and now grapplers
have arrived too
it makes the combat more intense and
exhilarating when you don't know what to
expect using everything in the moment
like
knives in the environment instead of
saving it because you know the bigger
enemies are going to be coming soon
the other combat form we discussed was
shooting i think it's fairly standard
combat you have a variety of guns and
the ability to take cover behind certain
walls
there is quite the easy exploit with
this however as you can activate slow
time when vaulting over covers so you'll
usually see me vaulting over cover
popping a couple guys then running back
behind the same cover and repeating that
cycle
i think it's quite obvious a lot of time
went into the different moves and
mechanics of hand-to-hand fighting
rather than shooting combat and i think
that's okay
not everything has to be amazing just
because you add something to the game
doesn't mean it needs to be the best
it's okay for certain mechanics to lack
so others can shine and i think the devs
knew this or they wouldn't have spent so
much time making the fighting combat
so seamless and smooth
now i like probably many of you have
explored more new places and locations
in video games than in real life
my traveling journey has really only
consisted of a couple states in the us
and that's really about it the reason i
bring this up is because i have no idea
what hong kong looks like
i could easily look at videos on youtube
but that's not really representative of
the full hong kong
experience i can confidently say however
that sleeping dogs is exactly what i
envisioned hong kong would be
13 year old me would picture bustling
city streets crowded marketplaces
temples and maybe the occasional rundown
neighborhood and it has it all
the island is split into four sections
north point central
aberdeen and kennedy town north point is
covered in tall grey buildings with
majority of its color coming from the
overarching signs
this is in stark contrast to central
which has palm trees across the streets
and more tall buildings but they look
more like corporate office buildings not
your typical residential living space
we don't even have to walk outside to
see this as the further we progress in
the game the more apartments we unlock
and each one gets nicer and cleaner
going from a small
one-room apartment with terrible
furnishings and low-quality amenities to
a multi-room
suite this whole map is accessible to
the player at any time
even though the quests at the beginning
do go from area to area once the map has
been uncovered and introduced to the
player via
these quests they start to vary in
location i like this as it doesn't seem
like a certain section of the map
shouldn't be entered yet because the
enemies may be too tough or the story
hasn't taken us here yet you're free to
explore wherever you want whenever you
want
on the map is a large amount of content
for the player to take part in at the
beginning it's quite limited in its
content
and the locations of said content but
eventually it will expand as to not
overwhelm the player with tons of
content right away they're uniquely
color coded to help the player identify
what is what
most things in blue are going to be
police related work drug busts to brawls
to full-on investigations
anything in oranges side content
cockfighting racing martial arts clubs
anything like that
and yellow is a favorite quest
increasing your face is like increasing
your reputation in hong kong the higher
your face the better rewards you can get
starting from the beginning like having
a valet bring you a vehicle of your
choosing to getting massive discounts on
clothing and cars pretty much the only
side content that i would consider
necessary is the favor missions but even
that you really don't have to do
these are small missions with many
having very little story to them as they
can last maybe upwards of two to three
minutes
there are very few recurring missions
such as cheaters never prosper and any
mission that involves calvin the street
racer keeps getting cheated out of wind
so he asks us to break the winner's car
who cheated there are three parts of
this quest all with the same premise
find the car break the car beat up the
guys who confront us the missions with
calvin are also very similar as well
usually calvin will ask us for a ride
and then commit some act of violence
whether it's knocking out a cop or
shooting up a store most of these
missions are very simple and won't take
too long to do and i've always felt that
these are necessary to break up the pace
of the quest when a player wants to do
something else
if the player still wants to do a quest
of some sort but not something with a
complete narrative to it that can maybe
be done in a couple minutes for some
easy xp and money then these are what
the quest would be
i mentioned earlier that the favor
missions are technically the only
necessary side content which means the
others aren't but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't do them the cockfighting
racing and especially the martial arts
club are some of my favorite things
about the game
all are fairly self-explanatory but are
very well made obviously we already went
over the martial arts club so i won't
need to explain that again
but cockfighting allows you to bet money
on illegal chicken fights occurring
throughout the different parts of town
it's a nice little activity to have some
fun with the races are also split by
class like most racing games do so only
certain class cars can race on certain
races so no one has an underpowered or
overpowered vehicle
something quite semi-hidden on the
minimap is when you scroll over a race a
line appears showing the actual race
track allowing you to prepare ahead of
time should a race prove too difficult
for you
but that's not all as there are two
other activities to do in the game that
while on the map may be hard to spot or
aren't color coded orange gambling in
karaoke
if betting on chickens isn't your thing
on the north and south points of the map
is a large boat which houses offshore
gambling dens the only game available is
mahjong poker but it spices up the
gambling scene of the game a bit karaoke
is by far one of the best side contents
in the game
instead of using buttons on the
controller sleeping dogs has you move
your left thumbstick up and down
all the way in one direction to hit the
top and bottom and a slight nudge to hit
the middle too
it can be quite uncomfortable since
there is times where you have to go into
the middle
then to the top then all the way back
down really quickly while not trying to
push the thumbstick too far but it's
definitely doable with enough time
throughout the game you can also meet
some girls that wake and take on dates
sadly this is one of the biggest missed
opportunities
there are five women you can take on
dates all of whom are quite unique
compared to the other but you can only
take them on
one date mine is sandra who is
technically two dates depending on how
you look at it
all of the dates have unique objectives
and experiences like taking pictures
with amanda
singing with tiffany or racing with
iliana these are all fun but you can
really only do one date and that's all
i felt like this was on purpose since
each date shows one of the collectibles
on the map completing amanda's will get
the health shrines and completing others
will get the jade statues the lock boxes
etc
it felt like the whole point was to date
for the reward not to have fun with them
i never really liked the dating system
of this game and while it's definitely a
negative aspect of the game it barely
dents the overall look of it so i don't
try to dwell on it too much
the side content and the exploration of
the game is very well made
hong kong doesn't hit much as night city
does for me where i can literally walk
around for hours just looking at the
environment but
in terms of actual content in the open
world there's enough variety and
quantity to make sure you're never bored
jay the [ __ ]
even though way is undercover in the sun
on ye that doesn't mean he isn't a cop
sleeping dogs provides the player with
numerous cop related jobs wake and help
the hong kong pd with from simple drug
busts to full-on investigations the two
side content police
jobs are drug busts and cop jobs the cop
jobs are part of a dlc pack that offers
around
20 different situations these are fairly
straightforward with small amounts of
variety depending on the location some
could be simple brawls but others could
be police shootouts
these aren't random when you start the
missions however just each one may be
different than the last depending on
which ones you chose so maybe you get
multiple scenarios in a row or maybe you
get three shootouts back to back
it all depends on what you tackle first
the second one is drug busts
these are the same every time the only
difference being the location
you arrive on the scene defeat the gang
members hang around the location
bug the nearby camera travel back to
your apartment and watch the camera to
spot the dealer
and once you're certain you've found him
you can call in to arrest him if you
fail no issue because you could just
restart the camera section and look
again and if you take too long the game
will just give it to you anyway
this was quite helpful since one of mine
ended up bugging out really quickly i
really like the idea of still doing cop
activities even though you're undercover
but i could just never get behind these
two
they were interesting and unique but
after doing them a couple times it's the
same thing and personally the drug busts
are the absolute worst since depending
on your location you may have to travel
quite far to get back home
so if you're trying to run through lots
of content and try to get one of the
drug busts done and then maybe go down
the street to get the other one you have
to go to the location
finish the handiwork go to your
apartment finish the job then go back to
the spot where you were before but just
travel a little farther to reach the
next one
you're basically driving around in
circles at least the cop jobs and right
where you started so there isn't an
annoying amount of backtracking
even though these two jobs lack in
actual entertainment in regards to the
cop side of sleeping dogs i think the
investigations more than make up for it
there's only four in the game and all of
them have a unique situation motive and
story
our first case is about a guy named pop
star who seems to be dealing some drugs
we need to have proof of him committing
a crime so we need to play along for a
bit
this requires us to extort money from
his customers and bug a nearby camera to
find his meet up location we eavesdrop
on the location and continue to follow
him to the docks until we see him shoot
his supplier
we photograph him in the act and call it
in it's not a terrible quest by any
means but it's a showcasing of what
these cases are about so it's a nice
intro to a first-time
player they start to ramp up in story
after this however as our next case is
about street racing inspector tang
explains that there's a lot of illegal
racing in hong kong and sometimes people
do die but these don't seem like
accidents
we call one of the street racers ace who
we challenge to erase
after the race we get a brief glimpse of
another racer hotshot we then get info
on his last known location
and use a city cleanup van as our cover
as to not look suspicious
we then bug the back of hotshot's car so
we can see where he goes we can hear
that hotshot is getting suspicious of us
especially since the song any just found
out they had a rat in their gang and now
we just happen to show up soon after
that person was just caught we still
have to play along as someone who just
entered the street racing scene of hong
kong so we challenge him to yet another
race
things die down from here as we don't
get any calls or reports of activity
from hotshot until we get a random call
from ace
hotshot's apparently trying to kill him
while he's talking with us and once we
finally triangulate his location we get
a call from his girlfriend
as we rush to the scene we see ace's car
burned and destroyed he's dead in the
driver's seat but at least his
girlfriend is alive we photograph
our proof and settle this dispute with
hotshot once and for all we end up
requesting a 1v1 race with him he's
extremely hard to beat but way has a
plan to get the cops involved in the
race
and they do is they set up a roadblock
and arrest hotshot as we escape
the third investigation is about a
serial killing six triad members are all
dead within a couple months and all were
sliced open it clearly doesn't make
sense so we're sent to investigate
russell told someone we know
is a part of the dead as we arrive on
scene we discovered that this is indeed
a serial killer and that our friend
was vincent if you don't remember who
vincent was when you first heard his
name no worries
neither did i he showed up occasionally
in the intro of the story
being a side character when he fought us
during the intro with conroy and then
when he was with us at the club later in
the game he didn't get as much screen
time as winston and conroy but was still
a part of the gang regardless
apparently every person we found at the
site were all sung on yi gang members
and the incisions were quite delicate so
this must be a professional checking by
the nearby hospital confirms this as we
find out that a doctor sang has been
working with the 18k
the rivals of the sun on yi to kill
samani members harvest their organs and
perform transplants to make money for
the gang this could be seen as a
finished case until we get a call that
our buddy calvin is the next target we
see calvin get abducted and i'm not even
going to ask how a huge guy like him was
taken down but
regardless we hijacked the vehicle and
drive him to safety we obviously can't
let him out of the trunk as then
that will blow our cover that we're an
undercover cop so we just let the hong
kong pd handle the rest our last
investigation occurs much later in the
game during one story mission we meet
with the rapper king and take him around
hong kong during this mission we meet a
girl at a nearby club called
iliana who gives us her number and a
couple days later she will call us
saying that her friend katushka who we
also saw at the club was possibly
abducted searching through her room
confirms these suspicions the place is
ransacked and no one is home
the only evidence we have is a phone
number which belongs to a yarkoi
lie who frequently gambles at the
offshore dens if we assume he is the
kidnapper then we need him to kidnap
another girl so we can follow him to the
hideout so we have to purposely lose a
game of mahjong poker while betting
ileana we throw the game and we chase
him to the hideout only to find out that
it wasn't just ileana and katushka but
two other girls are locked in the same
cage
after dealing with the guards we rescue
everyone and complete the case
these missions are some of my favorite
additional quests that allow you to take
on these realistic investigations that
are ended in one part but multi-mission
stories with unique motives and
situations that seem believable in the
current time period
kidnapping street racing serial killing
all these things make sense to be
backdrops for these investigations as
they're all quite common in the real
world
i think what helps these quests is the
pacing at which you can do them though
most of the time you can't do these
cases back to back you'll have to wait
some time before another appears this is
the same for even the multi-stage
sections of the same case
sometimes you can rifle through the
entire case one lead after the other but
just like before they can take some time
to appear so it breaks the pacing and
that mystery and withholding of content
intrigues the player
wondering what's going to happen next
when am i going to be able to continue
the mission and other questions like
that
i think the decision to keep the pacing
of each case varied and unique to other
cases makes it feel fresh and not
repetitive
this while also establishing realistic
situations and exceptional stories
ultimately culminates in an excellent
piece of additional content
son of a [ __ ] i'll kill you save your
energy mr shin
you need it the last cup i had in this
chair lasted almost 48 hours
would you like to try for a new record
we have finally come to one of the best
parts of sleeping dogs
it's story as always spoiler running
ahead for the story of sleeping dogs as
even though the game is years old at
this point if what i previously
mentioned has interested you i highly
recommend you experience the story for
yourself to recap like we stated before
we are wei shen
we just got into the water street gang
who is a small branch of the much bigger
organization the sun on ye
winston is the leader of the water
street gang and has not only been in
beef with 18k
but also the jade gang led by dog eyes
it sounds confusing but here is the best
way to put it on screen if you're a
little confused
jade and water street are both under the
sun on yi but both leaders are fighting
over territory so there's a civil war
going on while that's happening the 18k
is still the rival of both gangs and
more specifically the entire sun on ye
a small bit of information for those who
don't know i believe all of the gang
names in sleeping dogs are actually
references to real life gang names being
the water room gang
sun yeon and the 14k quite the little
easter egg for those who are
knowledgeable in that sort of subject
to pick where we left off way's still
trying to play the role of a gang member
and he expresses his annoyance with
winston who just keeps sending him on
errands
jackie understands his hate but explains
that both need to prove to winston that
they mean business and a good start is
screwing with dog eyes apparently he's
got a shipment of watches coming soon so
they're going to hijack it for
themselves
we rob the gang and we make off with the
watches although we do find out that
they're fake watches so we almost did
just good shot for some fake watches we
return to winston and he is pretty happy
that we have been crippling dog eyes
recently but he wants to keep the
pressure on him so over the course of
the next few missions we're gonna take
over dog eyes
bus route and talk some sense into a
past associate of winston's who is now
betraying him and working with dog eyes
while that happens i wanted to showcase
something sleeping dogs does really well
and its use of
other languages and dialogue now he's
working for dog eyes
that harm god is getting back at us for
taking his minibus route
many times in the subtitles he'll see
parentheses with english words in them
which show us the player what the person
is saying when they say certain words or
phrases in a different language
the only game i can think of off the top
of my head that does this is assassin's
creed and i've always
loved this it makes sense that the
characters actually know the language
they use and not just know it because
the game's settings but the language to
english
it's also nice for those who want to
know a bit of the hong kong dialect if
it interests them i've always
appreciated this in assassin's creed and
i love it here too i've said earlier
that there are two rival gangs the sun
on yi and the 18k
yet it seems like the sun and d are
fighting each other and you're not wrong
way brings this up when he meets with
raymond to debrief with him in person
saying that there's a civil war going on
and it's getting worse every day
raymond doesn't seem to really care and
only asks how way is doing
also briefly mentioning that way is
still undercover that he needs to not
act too emotionally since he still
believes wei
has a personal stake in this undercover
operation with dog eyes
technically being the one who killed the
sister when we go back to the golden koi
the energy is a little tense in the room
as the gang suspects way to be a cop
they started noticing a trend that since
way has arrived more of their gang
members have been arrested
was able to turn the conversation off
him and onto mingmo
[ __ ] wrath i sent you the pop star
but now he's in jail yeah
and who stands the game that moves from
that you're going to take over pop stars
whole kind of main racket now
no more scraps for you you'll supply the
whole city with drugs
you and dog guys pop stars gone but
you're still dealing aren't you
so who's supplying you
are you guys actually listening to this
[ __ ] he's a rat
this engagement to take some precautions
and bug the restaurant with a mic
as we enter we hear winston mention that
no cop is going to do what they're about
to do
so if way is a cop they'll know that
thing in question is a shootout against
dog eyes as men when we arrive at club
bam bam we find out that doga
shot up winston mother's restaurant the
golden koi so we're gonna go get some
payback
conroy like winston also doesn't trust
us yet either so
conrad wants us to find a gun and kill
some people ourselves
if they find out that we didn't kill
anybody then we have to be a cop
there are lots of guys in this warehouse
and multiple sections where we use and
don't use firearms eventually though we
do make it to the owner of the drug
plant being cy and escort him out of the
building this is a small turning point
for waze position in the gang is now
conroy and winston the two who have been
the least trustworthy in us so far now
acceptable as a full member of the sun
on yi and the water street gang
the next morning we go back to the club
and we hear from winston that we're
going to be going with him to meet uncle
poe the grand master of the sun on ye
uncle poe is definitely not happy about
the shootout considering the fact that
both gangs are still a part of the sun
on knees so while yes we did [ __ ] dog
guys production and wounded the jade
gang we also still wounded the sun on yi
because they still both work for them
winston gets sentimental with us here
saying that if anything happens to him
that we look after the gang
his mom and his fiancee peggy and that
everyone on water street is a family no
matter what happens
he also says quite the shocking sentence
that the triad business is a tough one
but no matter what happens
the one thing that keeps the water
streak gang going is their bond and
their brotherhood this winston is a lot
different from the winston in the intro
he's able to open up to wei
and that makes him quite the likable
character he's a leader he's got to be
tough especially in the triad business
but he cares for his family whether they
be biological or not and that means
something to him winston also informs us
on the chain of command in the game we
have uncle poe being the head master
then pockmark who is the advisor to
uncle po after them come the red pole
veteran members of the sun nani
including big smile lee
zhang zao winston and dog eyes and then
the regular members underneath them like
conroy jackie calvin et cetera when we
meet with uncle po he seems like a kind
old man but we do have to remember that
he is the leader of a triad so he
definitely has an aggressive side to him
uncle paul wants us to do a quick job
for a guy named roland but it definitely
seems like he wants us out of the room
so he can talk with winston alone we
also get to meet a new person named
ricky ricky works under big smile lee
and is one of his biggest backers along
with another member named sunny woe who
we'll get to later in the game
after this we get to talk with raymond
once again he's also quite annoyed about
the shootout as if it comes back that
the police were somehow involved it
could be huge problems for everyone in
the group raymond was close to pulling
the plug on the entire operation
until way brings up that he's now met
with the chairman which gets him even
closer to the goal of bringing down the
sun on yi we come back to the golden koi
and talk to winston's mom mrs chu
winston and peggy are getting married
soon and peggy needs to get more stuff
for the wedding and most importantly
see her dress we get a quick
introduction to peggy and drive her over
to the flower
shop she wants specifically black
orchids with her dress as she claims
that they mean the couple will stay
together for the rest of their lives
sadly there isn't any available in hong
kong anymore except at the nearby temple
so we just forget about it and go pick
up the cake
except someone stole the van with the
cake we chase the van down and get the
cake back and then later we end up
infiltrating the temple to get the
orchid anyway the monks however do not
take kindly to this and we return the
orchid to peggy and drop her off the
restaurant this will be the last time i
say it but spoiler warning ahead the
next mission is the
start of the climax of the sleeping dog
story if anything i've mentioned about
the story is remotely interesting to you
then click away now and play the game
with that however we come to the wedding
at the wedding is everybody
winston peggy mrs chu and tons more
people winston motions us over and says
that he has some of uncle po's favorite
wine and that we need to get it for him
as we go to the van to pick up the wine
we hear some shooting
as we enter the banquet hall we see that
the staff is trying to attack us we
managed to defeat the staff
and find winston
out of here cheek she doesn't
deserve this winston
winston [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] peggy
this mission is and always will be
heartbreaking both peggy and winston are
dead at their own wedding do you
remember earlier what peggy said about
the orchid
a black orchid at a wedding guarantees
that the couple stays together for the
rest of their lives
like [ __ ] man like i genuinely hate
talking about this mission it's so
depressing the wedding was supposed to
be this fun party to celebrate a
marriage between two people
and not only does the wedding get shot
up the bride and the groom die
at their own wedding it's such a great
mission but i dread playing it because i
know how terrible this outcome is it's
just
[ __ ] insane wei makes it outside and
finds that uncle poe was shot too
luckily we're able to get him to a
hospital before he succumbs to his
wounds
raymond once again calls to meet up in
its clear way isn't too happy
it's war now no it's not you're a cop
all right your job is to enforce the law
you can't remember that
i'll pull you out right now pull me out
your job was to get close to winston
now that's not much of a strategy
anymore get close to open your eyes
raymond
i am winston now with him gone i'll be
taking his place
you want the chairman i report to him
now you want the red poles
i'm one of them that's what worries me
way
you're one of them so we then learn wei
is now going to be a red pole as he's
taking over winston's position
obviously in this instance wei would
gather with the red poles at uncle poe
to discuss what to do next with the son
on yi but
firstly we got to talk to miss chu she's
currently grieving with a picture of
winston on her table and when we meet
with her we tell her that we may know
one of the gunmen and that we may be
able to bring justice to the situation
but he doesn't say to arrest him or kill
him but to bring him to the restaurant
instead
this person in question happens to be
johnny ratface johnny is hiding out near
the docks with a bunch of guards we go
through this long sequence of fighting
shooting and chasing until we hijack his
car and bring him to miss chew
i don't know what this guy told you
winston's i don't know what you're
talking about you crazy old [ __ ]
please wait maybe i can go down
because i'm going wait wait don't leave
me here she's [ __ ] crazy
okay okay i'll tell you anything you
want to know just please
don't
with johnny taken care of we can now
take care of the rest of the sun on ye
business
the group talks and starts throwing out
ideas as to who led the attack since he
already took care of johnny we find out
that he's an enforcer for dog eyes so he
seems like the one who led the attack
while the group argues someone named
ponytail approaches us he's a
representative of big smile lee and that
while the water street gang can continue
to operate in the night market like
before all the money's not going to go
to big smile lee and
nobody else because winston's dead
weight clearly doesn't like that and
threatens him at gunpoint for making
such a proposition
because of this big smile lee's gang
shoots up the club this leads to a
massive shootout and a chase scene where
we corner ponytail and fight him
except he escapes before we can kill him
while running from the police after the
encounter we meet with someone who helps
us out specifically
zhang another red pull of the sun on yi
she explains to us that if uncle paul
were to live from his injuries then
everything is fine business is usual but
if he dies they have no leader so she
would prefer
if way sides with her and not big smile
lee clearly after what happened over the
past 10 minutes
way's inclined to agree with her meeting
with mrs chu will confirm to us that it
was in fact dog eyes who led the attack
we like anyone in this situation would
do
confront dog eyes at his hideout just
like with johnny this is a sequence of
chases and fights until we finally
defeat him and bring him back to mrs chu
we get to see what happened to johnny as
he is now flavor for the food she made
for dog eyes forcing him to eat his own
gang member
jesus [ __ ] christ we get a call to
meet with everyone at the hospital
inside is uncle poe pockmark and the red
pulse before we are an official red pole
we need to do an initiation by making an
example of an ex-member who betrayed
the gang mentioned that anyone who wants
to be initiated into the gang should
join
us too so obviously we're going to call
jackie we then meet up with jackie and
take care of some business
as we can see from the rest of the
cutscene and the talk with jackie he's
freaking out he's never killed anyone
before so he's not used to the feeling
of taking someone's life we tell jackie
to relax the next couple days and he
definitely agrees as we attend the
initiation ceremony with him
we get another conversation with raymond
later and it's your typical conversation
pendrew wants us to look into this sunny
woe person as it's the next step into
the gang
raymond does mention however that he's
going to take jackie into custody
way's confused why of all people would
jackie be taken in
raymond claims that he can give info out
of him so we need to set him up wade
doesn't want to when of course raymond
is quick to point out that way's
becoming too attached to jackie
us the player feels the same way
everyone loves jackie he's basically a
kid
some goofy and funny guy we hang out
with a lot and we don't want him to go
to jail
we realize how little power we have is
an undercover cop as the next morning
when we do talk to jackie who has a plan
to steal some jewelry
we escape but he gets apprehended by the
police to add on to more problems the
18k
are trying to shoot up the hospital
where uncle paul is located so we work
together with ricky and fend off the
gang
the next set of missions we receive
after this aren't really integral to the
main story but we do eventually get
enough evidence we need to put sunny woe
away in jail and penju releases jackie
because of our agreement we had with him
a little earlier
saying that if we put sonny wo in jail
he'll release jackie pendrew also
congratulates us saying that we can come
in we don't need to do any more cop work
we're finished
around the time of these unimportant
missions we do find out that uncle poe
died in the hospital and that there
being no chairman
we win the son on thee is gone way isn't
satisfied however as he knows big smile
lee will just take over and if anything
make the sun
on ye worse pedro says that if we
continue to work with the sun on ye
we're making a big mistake we would
later regret that mistake as we go to
the funeral to pay respects to uncle poe
the 18k
show up with pen drew and start a
shootout after the shootout the red
poles discuss who should be the official
chairman and big smile lee says that if
we don't vote for him in the election
process we're
making a big mistake judging for our
mistake from last time with pendrew this
probably can't be good either and it's
not as big smile lee sends his game to
attack us at the golden koi for anyone
paying attention you may be asking
where's jackie during all this really
good question he's currently being
buried alive on an island
yup jacket check the [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] man you're alive oh my [ __ ]
[Music]
apparently big smile lee had him
kidnapped during the shootout at the
funeral on the drive back to the
mainland jackie starts talking about the
gang again
saying he's done with all of it he
doesn't want to be in the gang anymore
if this is what's going to happen he
thought being in the sun on yi was going
to be this
fun and wild experience but now peggy
and winston are dead and he almost
joined them today
to help jackie out we do offer to scope
out the election spot with him first
thing tomorrow just so there is no funny
business beforehand
jackie
jackie
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh my god jackie [ __ ]
whey is now captured in being tortured
by the same guy who killed jackie
honestly jackie's death hit the hardest
it was the most out of nowhere death in
the game and personally and i may be
speaking for many when i say this but i
felt more attached to jackie we rarely
did missions with austin winston just
the two of us but
since the beginning we've been doing duo
jobs with jackie we beat up a ton of the
guys in the intro stole fake watches
jewelry and tons more with him and i was
gone way breaks out of his bindings and
kills everyone in his path
one thing that's always bothered me is
how he's able to struggle walking
straight one moment than able to do
numerous kicks and punches like
nothing's ever happened the ending of
this whole sequence ends with a 1v1
against tong who we kill with his own
machete after we escape we then reach
the final mission of sleeping dogs
kill big smile lee while we drive way
reflects on his whole journey this game
went from doing typical gang work
undercover to now taking down some of
the biggest heads in the gang over
things they did to [ __ ] overweight's
friends we killed dog eyes because of
winston's funeral and we're gonna kill
big smile lee because of jackie amongst
of other problems that he has
after cleaning through big smile these
guards we make it to his compound where
we get to gun down ponytail this scene
is probably a good time to mention this
but i've always felt that the reason i
like this game so much besides the
obvious reasons is that it always
reminded me of the chinese fighting
movies think like jackie chan
jet li all those movies that's the vibe
i've gotten from this game whether
that's actually true or not
who really knows it's just how i felt
about it movies like that have some sort
of plot armor to them that the game is
currently using right now
we just got cut open a bunch by tong and
took a shotgun shell to the shoulder
and he still has the capability to run
jump and climb over a ton of obstacles
and fight tons of guys at the same time
but then the story goes back on itself
as it makes him wounded because he was
punched a couple times by big smile lee
i understand i get it i get it i'm being
a prick and i'm nitpicking small details
again i get it but it doesn't take away
from the overall impact of the scene
it's just a weird confusing moment i had
when playing way eventually overcomes
big smile lee and throws him into the
ice machine and we have officially
beaten sleeping dogs we do get to see
some extra cutscenes that are quite
important as we eventually get a video
from
zhang of the hospital footage and find
out that pendrew actually killed
uncle poe judging by the officer shin on
the folder zhang knows we're a cop but
since we've helped her gain power in the
gang and become the new headmaster it
seems like she's willing to overlook
that detail
we also send pendru to jail and more
specifically the same jail that has all
the criminals we put away like sunny woe
and all the guys who want revenge
against pendrew you ready for life in
prison what
because all your old buddies are gonna
be waiting for you
i made sure they found out what you did
to uncle po that's a [ __ ] death
sentence
i know where you can't
i won't last a day in there that's the
plan
sleeping dog's story is one of the best
pieces of video game fiction i've played
in a while
it set up the setting and plot right
away and would eventually show the
player that not everyone is going to
live not everyone has this plot armor it
gave us the opportunity to briefly
glimpse into the work of undercover cops
trying your hardest to not be attached
and stay focused on the mission but
knowing that in the back of your head
you care for the people you're with it's
hard not to like the water street gang
and the game does this on purpose by
setting up the backstory that way and
the others grew up together in old
prosperity so they're not just from
random people they're to his childhood
friends
this on top of making the characters
likeable and having them show us their
soft sides by giving them the ability to
open up about how they feel like with
winston and his brotherhood and jackie
and his current feelings about the gang
make it even harder to dislike them as
people whether you're undercover or not
way claimed throughout the game that he
wasn't getting attached and even if way
wasn't truly getting attached to the
gang
us the player were maybe raymond's talk
about attachment to the gang were to us
and not to weigh i liked the water
streak guys winston
conroy vincent jackie all of them are
really cool and unique and fun to do
jobs with so even
if way wasn't getting attached i was and
i think that's really the point
oh
i usually don't like ending videos on a
sour note like this but i felt it would
make sense to discuss the story first
than the dlc's after the reason i say
sour note is because i personally don't
like the dlcs all too much
minus the pre-order bonuses the game has
24 dlc all of which come with the
definitive edition of the game
20 of them are packs that include
vehicles outfits skins and such but the
other four is what i want to focus on
more
two of them are in-game dlcs and the
other two are seen on the main menu when
you load up the game
out of these four i really only like the
zodiac tournament the nightmare at north
point is okay but the other two i'm just
really not all that into for the in-game
dlcs we have the zodiac tournament and
wheels of fury remember when i said
sleeping dogs it reminds me a lot of
those chinese fighting movies and that's
why i like them so much
well this dlc is exactly that the whole
thing from the film green texture over
the screen so the title card makes this
feel like a full production film
according to the wiki apparently this
dlc might be a reference to the movie
and to the dragon with bruce lee and if
that's the case that makes a ton more
sense in the dlc we travel to a nearby
island via boat and discover we're part
of a legendary tournament
some of the richest people in asia have
attended and have bet millions on this
tournament and it feels alive in here
with people up and down the temples
training and sitting around waiting for
the next match
it's nice that it feels like a large
celebrated event not just seven random
people who were picked to fight each
other the owner of this tournament is a
man by the name of zhang and he states
in the beginning of the tournament that
it will be very tough as everyone
attending are some of the greatest
fighters around the world this game even
recommends that you upgrade your health
more so that the dlc is easier but i
decided against it our first match is
between a bunch of random martial
artists this is very similar to the
martial art clubs
in the main game except with hazards
we're then instructed to follow the path
to the back of the island where we get
to see some more fights with other
contestants until our first actual fight
arrives
unlike the typical no-name contestants
all the bosses have unique fighting
styles and moves making it harder to
block them which i liked a lot
most of the moves enemies throw in the
game are telegraphed quite easily but i
found myself getting hit by these more
making it seem like an actual back and
forth fight not just a one-sided brawl
the bosses also have quick time events
like the grapplers do and yes while
after some time they do get a little
repetitive and telegraphed the first few
times did mix me up
because i didn't know a button to press
when a grappler grabs you from behind
you would know immediately to spam y
to break out of it it's not a challenge
anymore but by changing the button
slightly for the bosses it makes it a
bit more refreshing
after the fight we continue to explore
the island until we meet a contestant
who offers us tea which we find out has
been poisoned
it seems like the rich people who
attended the fight wanted to see someone
get poisoned and fight someone and that
just happened to be us
we then beat george who has a lot of
ground moves more than we've seen all
game he's pretty much a pushover though
if you remember the button inputs as i
don't think he landed a single grapple
the entire fight i'm not entirely well
versed in different fighting styles but
throughout the map you'll find these
fire opal statues that talk about 12
versions of fighting from muay thai to
kenpo and some of these styles are seen
in the fighters we face
muay thai is described as striking knees
and elbows and mma is more of a
combination of wrestling and striking
it's a small change but i'm glad the
devs overall decided to make new moves
for these bosses and not just new moves
but new moves dedicated to specific
fighting styles it makes it feel like
two intelligent fighters are battling we
have wei shen being someone who i
wouldn't say is a master of one style
but able to adapt and improve his style
to his liking
versus george who's a master of mma the
two use their training and knowledge to
fight one another in this 1v1 legendary
battle
after wade defeats george he finds the
flowers he needs to cure the poison and
then is sent to fight one more time this
is different however as after a couple
of guys are defeated
four are left and zhang mentions that
one shall live as the ceiling will
continue to lower until everyone is
crushed by the spikes wei and the other
three contestants agree that no matter
who wins the fight they will end up
beating zhang after this fight this is
some of the most intense fighting i've
had in a while you're able to throw
people into the gears to stop the
ceiling from coming down faster but even
when i did that i was
really cutting it close to the end the
game threw out multiple brawlers who
have more health and block most of my
attacks so i couldn't just spam moves
until they fell over i not only had to
be quick but smart about my fighting and
any mistake could end up killing me once
we're declared the winner we challenge
zang who we go through a chase scene all
around the island until we come back to
the first fighting location
and we discover that he's actually a
master of the drunken style this is a
moveset of weird abnormal movements that
mimic someone who's intoxicated it's
quite a hard style to fight against
since it breaks the fundamental aspects
of fighting since the movements are so
different it's an excellent and
entertaining fight and i probably
wouldn't have cut it as close as i did
in the gameplay if i had realized i
could have parried one of his attacks
earlier as he kept using that a good
amount of the time
but even if i figured that out earlier
he was still keeping me on edge he's not
like other opponents who i can just use
the counter button against i would
sometimes not only have to do a quick
time event but also press the counter
button shortly after making it a very
tough fight
overall the dlc just like the next one
we're going to be mentioning took around
30 minutes to beat so it's not too long
but i do wish it was a little bit longer
the dlc kind of felt a little rushed to
me towards the end where we go from
1v1 fights to a four man brawl then
killing the master all in around 30
minutes
i was assuming this tournament was going
to be a multi-day event with certain
times to train and fight and maybe
someone would sabotage you at night like
with the t and force you to fight not as
healthy for your upcoming fight or maybe
you eavesdrop on a conversation with
zhang and some of the rich viewers that
talk about killing someone and you watch
as someone gets killed during the fight
you were spectating so now you have a
reason to put a stop to the tournament i
don't know maybe it's just me but i felt
like i was left craving more there could
have been some time to form some small
relationships with the other contestants
maybe participate in a 2v2 fight with
that contestant or maybe be forced to
fight to the death with that fighter
we've taken a liking to nevertheless it
was a fairly good dlc with lots of
unique fights thanks to the new movesets
that the fighters got and i would
definitely be replaying it again
the same however cannot be said for the
wheels of fury dlc this dlc starts with
the person named dr tang who has quite
the unique problem
he's building this invention but the
whole thing can't go through customs
into hong kong so the parts were shipped
separately and because of that a rival
gang has stolen the prototype which just
happens to be a supercar we first have
to find the supercar amongst the fakes
that the 18k
are driving we know we have the right
one as the car will blow up if we're
wrong i honestly don't understand how
the cars haven't blown up right now i
understand it's for the sake of gameplay
and once again i'm nitpicking but
technically the cars should have all
blown up by then once we do find the
correct car we can bring it to dr tang
and all the missions after this
are missions testing out the new
upgrades for the car including an emp
mounted machine guns as well as a couple
other smaller upgrades like ramming
damage and overall speed increase
at the end it easily becomes the fastest
and deadliest car in the game and dr
tang wants to test out its thing in full
glory with a local race against a bunch
of gang members who want the car for
themselves
it's a pretty cool car sure i just can't
really get behind the mission of it the
car depending on how fast you go is
actually extremely hard to control
causing you to crash more times than
you'd think and something about the car
just kind of irks me a bit
i'm cool with sport and supercars in the
game but cars with mounted machine guns
and an emp
just kind of bothered me like it doesn't
really fit in the game i don't know if
you've ever played this dlc let me know
what you think about it because i've
always been
quite indifferent about it the last two
dlcs as stated before are located on the
main menu and have separate saves and
playthroughs so your money and upgrades
may not transfer over
it's unclear what exactly stays and gets
added since in the main game i didn't
even collect half of the hell shrines
but the dlcs assume i've collected all
of them but i'm also not allowed to use
the dim mock counter in the dlcs which
is the last jade statue upgrade which i
have so
i'm honestly a little unsure of what's
added and taken away but either way it's
really not that big of a deal the first
dlc is nightmare in north point while on
a date with not ping a ghost known as
smiley cat arrives and possesses the
citizens and abducts her he also summons
other ghosts from hell called the zhang
shi to fight us we catch up at smiley
cat before we can even attempt to fight
him though he leaves we then head back
to the golden koi and we find vincent
for vincent if you remember is dead he's
one of the victims of the serial killing
we mentioned earlier in the video he
gets a lot more screen time in here and
is actually a very entertaining
character
vincent mentions that there's something
out back and there's this giant demon
called the yaogwa we aren't able to
defeat him just yet as we need some
special ingredients to make a stew which
should give us some magical powers
along the way we find out that vincent
is going to be staying with us for most
of the dlc
we get a chance to talk and hear about
him more and honestly it's one of my
favorite moments of the dlc
we end up obtaining the ingredients
necessary to fight the yao gwaii and
with our new powers we can confront
smiley cat when we drive over
vincent lets us in on some information
about this smiley cat person
apparently his original name was big
scar wu and he ended up getting killed
by uncle poe who ordered some gang
members to kill him and they did so by
stabbing him 42 times
his body was then put in a grinder at
the smiley cat factory so he became
bargain brand cat food
literally when he encountered smiley cat
he summoned some familiar faces
johnny ratface dog eyes and ponytail who
we all saw die in the main campaign
so now we have to kill them a second
time johnny and dog eyes are similar to
the last time where it's a bunch of
fighting combat until we reach them and
then challenge him ponytail actually
gives up as we strike a deal he tells us
where smiley cat is and he gets to live
in the afterlife peacefully we find
smiley cat at the nearby temple and the
reason we arrive here is because
ponytail also told us how to beat him
uncle paul kept smiley cat's pinky
finger here so that he can never rest in
the afterlife since a part of him still
remained on earth so we need to go to
the temple and burn it smiley cat is
obviously not going to just let us do
that
so we fight him alongside several yao
gwai and zhang shi
we do end up defeating him and saving
not ping and also giving vincent some
noodles
and then we also get a nice little
cliffhanger showing that he can still
possess people even when he's fully dead
it's overall not a bad dlc vincent's
commentary was a nice highlight and
being able to fight the other dead
members we already killed was a nice
touch since they referenced our last
encounter with them quite frequently
i managed to beat the dlc in around 50
minutes most of this was because i did
very little side
content in the dlc the only thing these
pieces of side content actually give you
to my knowledge is an achievement or
trophy so there's really no reason to do
them in game
this was coupled with the fact that i
disliked half the combat in this dlc and
this was an even bigger reason to not do
the side objectives
the fighting is the same as before in
the main game nothing's really changed
just how you defeat the enemies has
changed to defeat the zhang shi you have
to press the grapple button to fully
destroy them
or if there's a spawner you have to
throw them into the spawner to stop them
from respawning the owl quad can be
killed when you achieve a full face
meter and get access to those magical
powers with the stew we made
individually these are fine just
tweaking one core part of the game is
okay but when you add all three of them
into the dlc and sometimes even in one
fight it just becomes a chore
now instead of focusing on doing damage
and actually fighting i feel like i'm
taking things off my checklist of what
to get done first
oh there's a portal well let's grapple
them and throw them in if they attack
then just press
counter and then grapple them again now
the portals are down let's defeat the
yao gwaii since the zhang shi will
constantly spawn
so the player gets some way to get a
face meter then when the yaogwa is dead
finish off the remaining zhang shi and
then move on to the next encounter it's
always like this order because it's the
easiest to do unlike in the traditional
combat which also occurs in the same dlc
where it's typical hand-to-hand fighting
where you swing first at the nearest
person and anyone who wants to swing
back is gonna get countered
yes sometimes in the traditional combat
there may be an order to things like
killing the brawlers or grapplers first
because they're tougher enemies but it's
not always possible depending on the
situation
plus the zhang shi and yaogwa have a
necessary way to defeat them a grapple
or using the full face meter you could
defeat any regular enemy in the game
any way you want you have the freedom to
choose but not with these creatures it
made the combat a chore and seeing as i
rambled for quite a long time but
why i love this game's combat you could
see why this is a negative to me our
last dlc and last talking point of the
video
is the year of the snake whey has pissed
off lots of people it's quite meta since
they refer to our constant property
damage and destructive methods of force
so because of that way is now a typical
street cop handing out tickets and
dealing with small disputes
until he gets himself in a much larger
problem we see a couple suspicious
people all dressed very similarly after
apprehending a few we discover that
there's a bomb in one of the cars so we
drive it into the ocean away from the
public the license plate on the car
takes us to a warehouse which has tons
of confusing items signs posters and
plastic explosives
it's also here where i discovered one of
the most wild takedowns i've seen in the
entire game
honestly i'm genuinely surprised that
not only did i not kill him from this he
shrugged it off like it was nothing what
kind of guys are we dealing with here as
way finds out for us something is going
to be happening on new year's these guys
were led by a master chew
this guy also has the most punchable
voice i've heard in this game so far
i don't know he's helping
we're all helping the rest of the game
from here is basically just doing jobs
that prevent their uprising like
defusing bombs stopping riots and
killing the cult members after an
insanely long time we discover where the
masters location is which is one of
those offshore gambling denton ships we
then confront and beat the master
and complete the dlc so where to start
with this
the story and premise was okay
especially in the beginning where it
seemed like
a small petty crime which led to a
bigger conspiracy where i lost interest
was after we talked to the guy at the
prison
every mission from after this to the
ending was what i just explained
bomb defusal fighting and shooting this
lasted an entire
hour and three minutes to be fair more
than an hour's worth of the main game
was fighting and shooting so what's the
difference
actually a ton one mission after another
we got calls or texts about bombs
riots and that's all no story
progression we didn't get any closer to
finding the master until the last
mission when inspector tang calls us
technically we were making progress
since in the context of the story we
were stopping the attacks from the
cultists but it never felt like we were
moving the story anywhere just doing
side quests with no real meaning
something to raise the stakes of the
mission would have been great yeah a
bomb being planted in a crowded place is
definitely a tense situation but after
doing this for the third or fourth time
it's quite stale maybe having the
cultist capture inspector tang or bring
her to the island which could then segue
into the final
mission would have just been really nice
to at least change up the pace of this
dlc
the dlc of sleeping dogs is not terrible
by a long shot they each tell a unique
story that will intrigue some players
and i would definitely recommend that
you at least play them as your opinion
may differ from mine but
would i recommend multiple playthroughs
probably not maybe the zodiac tournament
if you want to run through specific boss
fights again since the dlc does allow
you to skip certain missions
as for the other three i'm personally
going to stay away from them
sleeping dogs is unlike any game i've
ever played and if you've watched any
part of this video i think it's quite
evident why i think that some may not
agree with my problems with the game and
that's entirely okay
games are meant to be judged and
critiqued and it shows your true passion
and affinity for a game if you can still
call a game great while addressing its
obvious faults as opposed to just
ignoring them and saying the game is a
masterpiece with no issues when we all
know that's not true
sometimes when i do these videos i worry
that i won't be able to talk long enough
about a game and i have this irrational
fear that it turns out to be some quick
six minute video there's nothing wrong
with a short video but i've always
enjoyed making longer content especially
when it's about a whole game it'd be
weird if i condensed an entire game like
this video to just six minutes
the only thing that worries me now is i
may have had too much to talk about i
was thinking this was going to be a
simple six to seven page video essay and
currently i'm on page 18.
so future me when i edit this is going
to have a blast
but anyway thank you all for joining me
today as we look through sleeping dogs
if you do want to pick this game up for
yourself it's around 20 to 30 dollars
usd
both physically and digitally i highly
recommend the definitive edition which
comes with those 24 dlc that we
mentioned which is definitely worth the
30 dollars
with that like the video if you do enjoy
if you are new here subscribe and check
out my new playlist i made filled with
video essays like this that you may also
like and if you're a returning viewer i
thank you for coming back
as always take care everyone and goodbye
[Music]
hmm